oh hey welcome to it's personal a show
about what makes you you today we're
talking about technology and how or if
it affects your life juice well Brandon
no whoa whoa cool where are we
I think the sugar from the oj must have
worm hold us into the mainframe machines
computer no really yeah I mean probably
I don't know hey Shane yeah ah what what
are you doing trying to triangulate our
position so I can find a way to hack us
the heck out of here oh well you know
looking down to your phone like that can
be a real pain in the neck
good one Brandon thanks but in all
honesty a lot of people have been
looking down at their phones and media
devices recently and did you know that
every inch that you lean forward you're
actually adding what feels like 10
pounds of pressure to the back of your
neck I did not know that well don't
believe me check this out oh my name is
dr. Julie Foster and I am a chiropractor
so text neck is really a syndrome which
just means that it's a group of symptoms
that we've developed specifically from
the way that we hold our media devices
so our cell phone specifically well the
symptoms can vary from first in a person
but it's really common to find patients
who complained of neck pain for sure
shoulder pain headaches tension and
definitely difficulty in the way that
they're able to turn their heads when
you keep leaning your head forward we
pull it out of that natural position
normally everybody's head weighs I don't
know 10 or 12 pounds depending on how
smart you are but the further you go
away from your body the more force that
your head applies to your neck so as I
pitch more and more forward my head
becomes literally heavier to up to
weights like two and three maybe six
times its normal weight so it's really
significant strain over long periods of
time
I'm Candace I'm Jared my name is Henry
I'm an awesome texture I probably spend
like six hours of the day like just at
the computer like this I'm really
worried that I'm gonna develop an old
people hump which is a very scientific
term I've noticed in pictures that like
my shoulders are forward and they're not
nice and pulled back even if it like
feels like they are I definitely have
back problems and like posture problems
I'm not activating my core enough even
though I think about it is that you're
talking you're talking to a smoker and
it's just like oh do you think the
reason why you're short of breath is
because you smoke all the time
yeah probably I'm not a doctor I don't
have an x-ray of my lungs and farming or
the medical expertise to make that call
but if I had to guess yes the answers
that I do have text neck the first
things I always look at is to see where
people's shoulders line up in relation
to their body you can see that her
shoulders are pitching forward or
pulling forward so what we'd really like
to see is for those to be set back here
look how that immediately kind of opens
up her chest Candace when I pull your
shoulders back is a little less tension
on your neck yeah miracle I feel more
ladylike yes you look so ladylike right
nice and easy looks comfortable than me
it looks really really comfortable right
now
are you comfortable no not at all it's
not at all what's pretty darn good to me
I might pull him back just a bit here we
go
you notice there's that little bit of
adjustment it brings his ears a little
closer in line I think over time you
have to pay attention to that but he
could certainly make that adjustment and
give himself a little bit less pressure
here but it's easy when you're standing
here and a doctor is poking at you
computers cell phones these things
aren't going anywhere
so to kind of blindly put it aside and
say that you shouldn't use your cell
phone as Modric shouldn't use your
computer as much really doesn't deal
with the issue it's up to each person
individually to become more mindful
about their bodies one of the things
that happens with technologies it allows
us to disconnect from other things
whether that's people are places or even
ourselves but your health is based on
your connection to you so absolutely use
your cell phone stay connected to
BuzzFeed but for all intents and
purposes please lift your phone up lift
your eyes up listen to your body pull
your shoulders back breathe deeply and
all of these things help you keep your
posture in mind so we should hold our
phones like this yeah yeah it's the best
for your neck all right but we look like
idiots now I mean yeah it is pretty dumb
but that's just the way that phones are
designed now but if you think about it
maybe someday in the future we're gonna
have like pala grams or like crazy eye
implants or maybe we'll be able to just
send information directly to each
other's minds oh yeah oh wait guys I got
a signal oh all right here we go my
phone just died
I wonder what happens when I die Kate
we're not gonna die in here
no I mean we spend all this time
updating our Facebook's or Twitter's our
instagrams what happens to all those
digital memories we were gone
I don't know watch this everybody wants
to talk about death right I mean bad
news is you probably can't decide how
you're gonna die in real life the good
news is you can't decide how you're
gonna die or whether you gonna die at
all online cash you a question hey Jamie
could you share with us the last
Facebook posts that you have my brother
wrote take ten minutes to watch my
sister talk about Pew I went to a cheese
club meeting where we dressed up in
cheese hats and everybody brought all
their favorite cheese's I recently
posted this photo of Lenny Kravitz
blowing out the crotch of his pants and
his his dong is hanging out so if you
were to die tomorrow do you feel happy
about these posts I guess if I died
tomorrow this would be my legacy
this cheese Club I don't know I mean is
this my legacy my legacy would be dick
pics
well so how do you avoid the legacy of
dick pics well you need to do some
planning but luckily there are options
option one takes trust and reliable pals
so if you got both of those go out today
and share the passwords for your Twitter
Instagram Gmail Hotmail etc etc with the
person you love the most
for Facebook you don't need to share the
password just go into your settings and
designate someone to take over a buddy
lover a jilted lover heck it's up to you
option 2 this takes more work but less
trust use online services to store your
passwords to unlock after your passing
or use an account like dead social where
you store messages and photos that will
be posted after death and intervals
surprising and haunting your loved ones
for years into the future
so once the appropriate preparations
have been made it's time to make some
real decisions first decide if you want
your Facebook to shut down or become a
memorialized page you could do
absolutely nothing but every year your
friends will get the reminder to
birthday and they might not like that
lastly think about what your final
messages and photos will be what's the
lasting impression you want to leave on
the digital landscape store this online
or give it to the person in charge of
your account what do you want your last
message to be you know that is crazy you
can't choose your final words in real
life but you can choose your final words
online
what would your final words be I don't
want to die well that's not original no
I mean I don't want to die in here guys
Brandon everyone has to die that's the
circle of life
well maybe we don't have to die yes you
definitely do a hold on Kate wait what
are you saying Shane have you guys ever
heard of the transhumanist movement
I have not it's a group of people
dedicated to the advancement of medical
technology with the hopes of prolonging
life possibly indefinitely
observe
death it's all around us technology also
all around us can we use the ladder to
cure the former one man believes we can
and he is here with us today please
welcome mr. Zoltan Istvan we want to
talk today a little bit about
transhumanism transhumanism is an
international movement a few million
people around the world that want to use
science and technology to radically
change the human being and also
radically change the human experience a
lot of it seems kind of far-fetched but
I feel like there's a lot of
technologies out there today that
probably fall under the umbrella of
transhumanism transhumanism is whatever
you sort of want to think about is it
the first time we picked up a rock and
made an axe or is it really a jet
airplane flying at 30,000 feet but I
like to think of driverless cars as
transhuman I like to think of the
artificial limbs that we put on War
veterans what other technologies do you
think are kind of down the line or in
the near future
one of the most futuristic type of
technologies that a lot of people love
to think about is mind uploading and in
fact as a journalist I write about that
a lot
eventually we're going to have our own
avatars in machines but that opens up so
many different avenues of thought and
artificial intelligence and 10 or 15
years could be 10,000 times smarter than
us so our mind our upload in mind is
going to tap into that artificial
intelligence and be 10,000 times smarter
than us that sounds kind of intimidating
to talk to some of yourself but
infinitely smarter it would be very
scary I mean because you you want to
have some randomness you want to make
some mistakes but this smarter self may
not make me mistakes yeah it might be
like Zoltan that doesn't sound very good
to me do this and I'll be like hey I'm
tell me what to do if we get to the
point where we're physically we don't
have to think about death quite as much
it becomes a choice what do you think
that does for us well not dying as a
species is going to dramatically affect
everything I mean just think of it for
example if you were going to live a
thousand years you would do other things
career things or you would go traveling
or you would just become a guitarist and
singer you know at a bar in the Bahamas
or something I mean there are a million
things we would do I feel like I'd stick
around for a while Oh totally totally
every instrument of course you'd be an
expert you know I want to be an
astronaut I want to be
professional surfer so let's talk about
the transhumanist party we're a small
political party then founded about a
year ago broadly the community is
interested in using politics as a means
to further the transhumanist agenda
which is just to say let's promote
Science and Technology more instead of
for example spending trillions of
dollars on far-off wars why not have the
American government spend all that money
on a war on cancer I mean this is really
what my presidential campaign is about
is just trying to make waves try and
enter the national conversation and say
hey don't you think we can do better
don't you think we can spend money on
our health on our longevity slowly we
can overcome any kind of disaster any
kind of problem that we have as a
species by putting in these bionics or
robotics or 3d printed organs that will
help us become a stronger species this
is really important for example you know
imagine if the dinosaurs had the bionic
lung they might have survived that that
would have been bad for us though yes
very much
we'd have a rough go of it who's that at
the door so the future's looking bright
is the point here 100% we just need to
put resources instead of putting money
into bombs and far-off wars let's put
the resources into technology and
science and let ourselves live twenty
thirty a hundred years longer
spectacular soul time thank you so much
for joining us today and may you live
forever may you live forever too
I can't wait
man do you really think we can live
forever not right now but if you think
about it in 1900 the average life
expectancy was only about 47 with
today's advancements in medical sciences
it's not uncommon for people to live to
60 70 or even older so someday soon it
might not be uncommon for people to be
living up into the triple digits yeah
but you're supposed to die hold on but I
don't want to die I'm gonna vote for
Zoltan me too yeah yeah but we are gonna
die in here though so I guess that
doesn't matter
yeah for sure oh it's happening oh hey
look it's Colin hey it's Colin oh hey
guys what are you doing in there no time
to explain just pour some milk on the
keyboard okay
oh holy yeah how'd you know that was
gonna work I don't know
well neat yeah you know oh by but by
milk huh yeah it's this basic science
stuff
what were you looking for on the
computer porn okay perfect